hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast
I'm your host Sean Carroll hope everyone
is more or less staying home and staying
safe in these surreal times that we're
in with the kovat 19 quarantine lockdown
etc it's very challenging out there for
everyone as I said frequently probably
less so for me than most people since I
basically work from home and I a pretty
comfortable situation here but it's
different you know you don't get to see
your friends don't get to socialize
don't get to eat out don't get to go to
class in the same way one thing that
struck me is how really different it
would happen if something like this
happened before we had computers and the
internet right of course plagues and
quarantine Xand pandemics did happen but
just the idea that we couldn't talk to
each other over zoom or send emails or
get updates I think it would be much
worse it would certainly be very very
different so it's appropriate that we
once again turn to the world of
computers in this week's episode of
mindscape and a particular the challenge
of artificial intelligence we all know
that AI is becoming more and more
important not just as some hypothetical
future thing that will talk to us and be
our friend but right here right now
programs that figure out puzzles in a
way that you could think of as being
intelligent now there's a looming
problem here that everybody knows about
which is as the AI is become better and
better as they become smarter and
smarter more and more powerful it's
going to become increasingly important
that they act in ways that are what we
want them to do right they're
intelligent they can figure out things
to do for themselves it would be bad if
what they wanted to do in some sense and
we can figure out the extent to which
the word want is appropriate in the case
of a computer but what their goals are
are the same as what we want them to be
and this can be very difficult because
as anyone who's ever programmed a
computer knows it is very difficult to
say what you want it is very difficult
to put into precise algorithmic terms
what it is you're looking for that's why
computer programming is hard and so it's
very easy to imagine
asking a computer asking an AI to do a
certain thing and then realizing at the
end of the day we didn't really want
that we wanted something that was that
but there were some constraints that we
forgot to mention
so today's guest is Stuart Russell he's
a very big name in artificial
intelligence Stuart and Peter Norvig
wrote what is the classic text book on
AI called artificial intelligence a
modern approach even I have this book on
my bookshelf and I'm not really an AI
person so that shows you the
pervasiveness of that particular text
and recently Stuart has been thinking
about exactly this problem you know
making sure that AI is sort of do the
things that we wanted them to do when we
designed them so he has a new book out
called human compatible artificial
intelligence and the problem of control
and to really oversimplify it his
proposal is that rather than telling the
AI is what we want we will teach the a
eyes to learn from us what we want maybe
we don't even know what we want but
maybe the AIS can watch our actual
behavior and from that work backwards to
how they should be behaving to do what
it is we want now this opens a whole
bunch of other questions right so that's
what we talk about on the podcast you
know how realistic this is how much we
should be worried about super
intelligent AI and what it means for the
future more generally so anyway I hope
that you know the mindscape podcast is
contributing a little bit to taking our
minds off of the situation we're in with
pandemic you know I I don't wanna that
one one alternative would be you know to
switch all efforts into thinking about
pandemics and epidemiology and things
like that but I figured there's plenty
of people with more background knowledge
than I am doing those things so I'm
gonna try to keep mindscape more or less
the same kind of thing it always has
been I think it's still important to
keep thinking about other questions you
know pandemics and biology are part of
that medicine and networks and how
people communicate is all part of that
those are interesting things to talk
about and I'm sure we will but we'll
also be talking about physics and
biology and philosophy and culture in
the media and so forth remember that I'm
also doing a set of videos called the
biggest ideas in the universe
that are appearing on YouTube once a
week once week I do a big idea I was
really hoping to you know make these
around 20 minutes per idea
they've crept up to more like an hour
with me talking and scribbling little
pictures and and very primitive
equations but I hope people are finding
them fun so far has been you know more
or less classic ideas like space and
time and things like that but soon
enough you'll be getting to some pretty
wild ideas which I think are you know
not I'm not going to be speculating too
much when I choose the ideas themselves
we're not going to be doing like a
string theory or loop quantum gravity or
whatever but some of the ideas that are
part and parcel of modern physics are
pretty wild even the established ones so
we'll be getting into those and I hope
you enjoy those also and with that let's
go
[Music]
do it Russell welcome to mindscape
podcast it's nice to be here we're gonna
talk about artificial intelligence the
warnings that the worries that we have
are artificial intelligence and also the
prospects of it but I think that it'd be
a wonderful opportunity here since you
not only are someone who has specific
ideas about fixing any dangers of
artificial intelligence but you're also
someone who has been doing research in
this field literally wrote the textbook
etc to talk about some of the background
here so I thought I would just start by
asking you in your mind what do what
does the phrase artificial intelligence
actually mean how do you define that
term so obviously artificial
intelligence is about making machines
intelligent and what that has turned
into actually from right at the
beginning of the field is an approach to
building systems that are given
objectives by humans and then find ways
to carry out those objectives so the
identities might be goal so can you find
a plan that achieves this goal it might
be a reward function can you behave in a
way that that generates the largest
amount of reward for example can you
make money on the stock market so this
has been the way that the general idea
of intelligence has been instantiated to
build systems that act in ways that can
be expected to achieve the objectives
that we set for them and is there some
way of sort of definitively saying when
a certain computer program is AI versus
just a regular computer program I mean
in some sense isn't a pocket calculator
optimized to add numbers together
correctly yes and I think that's that's
part of the difficulty there really is a
continuum between something as simple as
a thermostat that you know switch is the
heat on when it gets cold and switches
it off when it gets warm all the way up
to humans and even beyond and the
continuum is mainly in the the nature of
the task environment how complicated is
the world that the the entity has to
deal with and then
is the actual objective and some
objectives can be achieved even in a
complicated world can be achieved with
very very simple rules and some for
example you know winning at a game of Go
or running a country or you know
teaching someone to speak French these
are very very complicated goals and they
take place in a very very complicated
task environment which is an environment
that includes human beings and that's
that's probably the most complicated
environment we know of is the one where
there are humans that are part of it but
you would say I mean I like the point
that there's a continuum here it's not
like if there is some sharp phase
transition between dumb computer
programs and artificially intelligent
ones that's right in fact there's a
Nostrum that's been put about a long
time that as soon as it works it stops
being artificial intelligence which
which is a little bit unfair because
then of course that means that the AI is
the field of continual failure but that
I think is that's in some ways accurate
that a lot of things that AI has
produced over the years for example
every time you you drive in your car and
you get directions there's an AI
algorithm running in your cellphone or
maybe in the cloud that is computing
shortest paths and incorporating
expected delays and so on this is a very
classical AI algorithm that was
developed in the late 60s and early 70s
and no one thinks of that as AI anymore
but of course you know someone had to
invent it and before it was invented no
one knew how to do it
and you know we we now I think take
speech recognition for granted but
that's another part of AI that's been
gradually improving for the last 50
years or so but now that it works and
and it's just one of the things that
runs on your cell phone you don't think
of it as AI anymore there is and that's
a pity because it works it also means
that there's a there's a tendency I
think of for students to not
want to study things that we already
know how to do yeah which means of
course that the students don't learn how
to do anything that works right but I
mean even you mentioned playing go as
one of the more complicated tasks but I
would sort of put playing go more on the
finding a route to your destination side
of the ledger and driving a car or
writing a poem on another side if we
think about the fact that the rules of
go are extremely explicitly defined and
even though the state space is huge the
space of possible things that can be
going on it's still finite right I mean
there is a right answer to every
question whereas these more human scale
things are a little bit fuzzier is that
is that a relevant distinction you think
it is yes I think there's multiple
distinctions being made here one is that
as you say the the rules of go unknown
so the objective is to win and that has
a precise definition that varies
slightly from country to country but
pretty much agreed on and you know that
when you put a piece on a square the
piece ends up on that square it doesn't
sort of run around by itself and go
somewhere else yeah and of course when
you're driving you don't even know the
rules you don't know what's gonna happen
when some other entity is involved and
making decisions about where they're
going to go which will affect your own
ability to to get what you want done
done so and the other part of driving
that's difficult is that the objective
is also not known mmm so obviously you
would like you know if you say take me
the airport you would like to get to the
airport but you don't mean take me to
the airport at all costs
you know so if there's an earthquake and
the Bay Bridge falls down again then
that doesn't mean you know drive me 200
miles around and get me to the airport
an hour after my flight leaves it
doesn't mean you know plunge into the
into the bay and and try to swim across
the bay when
give a human and objectives like take me
to the airport the human understands
under what circumstances is is it
reasonable to give up on that plus there
are many different ways of getting the
airport is it that you take the shortest
route is it that you take the fastest
fastest route and then how fast do you
drive how safely you do you drive do you
do you go right up to the edge of
catastrophe at all times in the hope of
getting to the airport a little bit
quicker and you know I've taken taxis
where that was how they drove and you've
taken other taxis we just want to say
look can you just get on with it
because they're extremely cautious so
there are many ways of driving and there
isn't and actually agreed on objective
for for what counts as good driving and
and how that depends on the circumstance
and the urgency and so on so so driving
is different from go in in both of these
dimensions and it's an unsolved problem
right now whereas I think we would say
that the go to the extent that that it
can be solved and and there are
mathematical reasons to believe that we
probably can't solve it exactly but to
the extent that we can come up with good
algorithms we consider the game go to be
one where a race had had success we've
beaten the human right well the
champions and and actually taught humans
things about the game that they didn't
know before
so you mentioned an idea that I think is
worth sort of lingering on and drawing
outs it's gonna be important for the
rest of the conversation
the idea of optimizing for some goal
right I mean I probably if you told a
person on the street that that's what an
AI program was trying to do they might
not instantly see the connection between
ordinary human intelligence I mean do
you think that we can think of all
intelligence as optimizing towards some
goal or maximizing some utility function
or something like that it's a good
question and I I would say that it's
taken a few thousand years to convince
at least one branch of the intellectual
community that that's a good way
thinking and the branch that's most
convinced about that would be the
economists right because they've reached
by by the 1940s they they reached a
formulation of rational decision-making
that is quite general so it allows for
the decision-maker to have uncertainty
about the state of the world about the
future it does at least in the original
formulation assume that the
decision-maker has preferences and this
is the way economists think about it
that if you think about each possible
future that could unfold in principle
like an expressive preference as to
which future I like better than which
other future and that's the basis for
then the economic notion of rationality
as utility maximization it doesn't mean
that you have to have a number in your
head which is the utility of each future
and then you have to add them all up and
divide by the probabilities and so on
it simply means that you act as if you
did and and you can be described as long
as you're not making mistakes then your
behavior can be described as if that's
what you were doing it doesn't mean that
you are actually doing that so for
example when my if I try to poke myself
in the eye with my finger my eyelid
closes now my brain is not doing
expected utility calculation to to
reason that I ought to close my eyes
because you know having a fingernail
poking my eyeball is painful and
dangerous and that would be a low
utility and so if I close my eye and
then I'll protect it no such thing it's
just an instantaneous reaction to a
looming object in the visual field but
it's still a rational thing to do in
other words if you were to do with the
expected utility calculations it would
tell you to close your eyes but you
don't have to do that calculation in
order to close your eyes I'm visualizing
thousands of podcast listeners trying to
poke themselves in the eyes as we speak
right here hopefully
like max tegmark said it didn't work you
know he tried to poke himself in the eye
and he succeeded yeah well someone who
used to wear contacts I think I've no
truck no trouble we're doing that
I love recommending the great courses
plus this is a streaming service that
gives you access to a huge variety of
courses from the great courses taught by
some of the best professors in the world
on a wide variety of topics you can
learn about everything from playing
guitar to practicing yoga to history to
science to literature I of course and
one of the professors at the great
courses I recently did you know my
little video on the nature of time for
the biggest ideas in the universe I did
a whole course for the great courses on
mysteries of time so if the hour-long
version was not enough if you want the
12 hour long version go to the great
courses plus look for the mysteries of
modern physics time learn about entropy
in the arrow of time but also about
timekeeping about time and particle
physics about the psychology and
neuroscience and philosophy of time the
great courses plus is giving mindscape
listeners a special offer a free trial
with unlimited access to the entire
library find all the details at the
great courses plus calm slash mindscape
that's th e great courses PL us dot comm
slash mindscape start learning today I
do and this is probably leaping ahead
and that's okay we don't need to go in
logical order
but you quote a theorem in your book you
wrote a wonderful book called human
compatible actually it is
that's that I'm not just saying that as
boilerplate I really enjoyed the book
and I encourage everyone to take a look
at it so there's a theorem by fun moment
in Morgenstern which if I understand it
correctly I've heard of it before and
then was reintroduced to it in your book
roughly it's that conclusion you just
said that if you're behaving rationally
then there's always a way to cast the
decisions you're making in terms of
maximizing some utility function is that
right uh yeah so it starts from a
description of what we mean by behaving
rationally that's pretty hard to argue
with and that that's how these these
kinds of proofs usually go you you
propose some axioms that sound
completely reason
and then you draw what appears to be a
very strong conclusion so the axiom say
things like you know if you prefer
sausage pizza to plain pizza and you
prefer plain pizza to pineapple pizza
then you prefer a sausage pizza to
pineapple pizza yeah right this is
called transitivity your preferences and
and what that basically says is your
preferences don't go round in a circle
and that seems perfectly reasonable
because if your preferences did go round
in a circle then basically you would pay
me to to go in the other direction so if
you like sausage better than plain and
you had a plain pizza you'd pay me to
get the sausage pizza and then if you
liked pineapple better than sausage you
would pay me to get the pineapple and
then if you like pineapple better than
plain so your preferences are now in a
circle you'd pay me to get the plane so
now you paid me three times and you're
back where you started yeah that doesn't
seem very rational so the axioms of a
rational behavior have this flavor but
they're really hard to argue with you'd
have to agree that an entity that didn't
follow those axioms would basically be
shooting itself in the foot all the time
and so and then the consequence of these
axioms is that the behavior of a
rational agent can be described as if
it's maximizing your utility function
good yeah and so that was the theorem of
von Neumann and what the main theorem in
that book but I think you've are also
already hinted at a little bit of a
tension there right because there's lots
of mathematical theorems that say that
something is possible in principle but
as you already mentioned with the poking
the I example for actual systems that do
something we called reasoning they might
not implement that design in order to
get things done but is it safe to say
that most a AI algorithms do try to
implement something like that that they
do actually sort of optimize over a
utility function over a whole bunch of
hypothetical actions yes or no so the
the biggest obstacle from the point of
view of AI
is that actually optimizing in many
situations is what we call
computationally intractable which
roughly means that if you if you really
want your algorithm to come up with the
optimal solution you're gonna have to
run it for you know until the universe
ends so billions and billions of years
of computation and then if you make the
problem
twice as big it's going to be and you
know a billion times more than that so
these kinds of problems
which we call computationally tractable
we cannot expect that any entity is
going to be able to behave rationally if
it has to solve those problems in order
to get what it wants so humans don't
behave rationally and we don't expect
that machines will behave rationally the
the interesting question is how much
closer to being rational can machines
get than humans particularly taking
advantage of their enormous
computational power so already we have
computers whose whose actual
computational throughput is larger than
even the theoretical maximum throughput
of the human brain and no one thinks
that in fact the human brain really is
able is able to use every single neuron
computing the maximum speed all the time
so the the interesting question is are
machines going to exceed the human
capability for decision-making in the
real world and when will that happen and
by how much will it happen but
interestingly you know humans have
developed over both evolutionary time
and during their lifetimes all kinds of
incredible schemes for overcoming the
computational difficulty of the problem
of deciding what to do and so even
though we're not particularly good at
playing go
in fact the a lot of games are
typically designed to not be easy for
our brains yeah our brains are actually
extremely good at organizing our
behavior into hierarchies so you know
when if if you're writing a book let's
say at any given moment your fingers are
typing one character of one word of one
sentence of one paragraph of a chapter
of that book and this is a natural
hierarchy just typing one character on
the keyboard might involve hundreds of
motor control commands from your brain
to your arm and your hands and your
finger as well as your eye to keep track
of what's happening on the screen if you
think about what alphago is doing which
is the go program that beat the human
world champion it's able to look ahead
in time maybe 50 moves into the future
which sounds pretty amazing but if you
apply that to a robot or a human body
where those 50 moves would be 50 motor
control commands to my muscles that
would only take you about 1/10 of a
second into the future so it would be
completely useless for real decision
making in the real world and humans of
course we think quite usually quite a
bit further than a tenth of a second
into the future sometimes even years we
plan to do a PhD which is five or six
years in other words a trillion motor
control commands are involved in doing a
PhD so we're planning at many many
levels of abstraction and we do it kind
of seamlessly somehow miraculously our
brain always has something lined up for
the present moment so that you're you
know if you're speaking you're your
tongue on your lips are saying the next
word if you're typing the next word is
coming out of your fingers if you're
going for a walk
the right things are happening for your
legs to move in alternation and yet the
the same thing is happening at the scale
of multiple seconds and minutes and
hours and days and weeks
and it all feels seamlessly we don't
we're not aware of sort of context
switching oh now I need to think about
what's happening in the next millisecond
oh now I'm gonna think about what's
happening an hour and a half from now
right it's it's all very smoothly
integrated and we really don't know how
to get machines to do this but this is
the main technique that humans use to
manage the complexity of the real world
yeah this is that's a really great
summary of a whole bunch of podcast
interviews that I've done you know with
people who do not see and cognitive
science and consciousness studies and
absolutely the message comes through
that human beings are these complicated
networks of subsystems each using little
heuristics to get through the day rather
than some perfect reasoning machine that
is trying to play a very abstract
version of go so but at the end there
you said and we're not very good at
converting that into an AI algorithm is
this something that people are trying to
do is this a huge difference in the
approach of conventional AI and where we
eventually want to be so it's something
that we've known about in fact Herbert
Simon who was a both for psychologists
and an economist who won the Nobel Prize
and an AI researcher one of the one of
the early a AI researchers who really
set some of the directions for the field
I wrote a very famous paper called the
architecture of complexity where he
specifically talks about this this
device of hierarchical layers of
abstraction that that help us to
organize our behavior in time and early
planning systems going back to the mid
70s attempted to implement some kind of
hierarchical planning capability so
there is actually a fairly well
understood ability if I give the
hierarchy to the system in other words
if I if I tell it ok these are the
primitive actions and then these are the
actions that use primitive actions to be
implemented so this is motor control
command for your fingers this is typing
a character this is typing a word this
is typing a sentence we have algorithms
that can construct long term
and people have used this to for example
organize the manufacturing process in a
factory you know for a month so that
month-long plan actually bottoms out at
something in the order of six hundred
million manufacturing operations that
are going to take place over that month
the difficulty is that those hierarchies
those abstract actions have to be
provided by the human so we are doing a
lot of the work and the one of the big
missing pieces in AI is how does a
system develop that hierarchy and invent
those abstract actions for itself I mean
there was a time when getting a PhD
didn't exist there was just no such
thing hmm emailing on googling someone
even a few years ago those didn't exist
we have a library of these things at all
kinds of levels of abstraction from
multi-year things like getting a PhD or
you know emigrating to the United States
down to much shorter term things like
googling something or or emailing
someone or texting and a lot of these
things actually we don't invent
individually they're gradually formed
somehow by cultural processes and we
inherit them
so in some sense then the intelligence
isn't really in the the individual human
it's it's something that we we've
inherited from our culture and it's
incredibly powerful without without that
sort of vocabulary of without that
library of abstract actions life would
be intolerably complicated and we simply
wouldn't be able to have the
civilization that we have because it
would be too difficult to navigate it
and to run it if we had to think of
everything in terms of these just the
primitive operations yeah I mean you
give an example in the book about I
forget the exactly the contest but there
was a the context but there's a question
you know a bunch of fourth graders are
going to have a rollerskating contest
what is the best kind of surface that
they should choose to move on your
gravel sand blacktop or whatever and you
talk about how much background knowledge
is necessary to even think about such a
question like what does it mean have a
rollerskating contest what is the goal
that the 4th graders have and so forth
and you seem to say in the book that
right now our computers are really bad
at that background knowledge and we I
had a conversation with Melanie Mitchell
on the podcast where she also argues
about the lack of common sense in our AI
algorithms it so you know again is this
something where everyone knows this in
AI and we're working hard and we think
we can crack it or is there a school of
thought that says well it'll just come
eventually if we keep working on what
we're working on now so that's a great
question I mean we've known it for a
long time there you know papers going
back to the 60s saying but absolutely
particularly in the case of
understanding language that we need this
background of common sense knowledge in
order to to make the right decisions and
for a long time there's a field called
knowledge representation where people
tried to actually capture the knowledge
in in mathematical form in typically in
mathematical logic and computer
algorithms are able to process logic in
order to do reasoning and we can even
learn these logical representations from
examples people found it quite difficult
to get it right so for example writing a
description in mathematical logic of the
process of making omelets turn or turns
out to be pretty difficult to get right
that you can you can capture some parts
of it with precise logical statements
but other parts of it are quite
resistant it's hard to say you know what
what you mean by you know not runny but
not too overcooked
and things like that so I would say that
effort is kind of on hold right now
there were valiant attempts to to build
up large-scale knowledge bases with lots
of common sense but those have not
turned out to be all that useful in
practice yeah so right now the AI
community is is working largely on
approaches based on deep learning and in
deep learning systems there is no
attempt to actually construct
representations of knowledge there's no
attempt to put in in common sense at all
we simply take data and we feed in the
data and use the data to Train very
large tunable circuits to perform
various tasks so you can put in image
data and train these circuits to
recognize the objects that appear in the
image but you know having trained an
image recognition system on on millions
of photographs of of animals they that's
all the system can do so it's now an
animal recognizer but it doesn't in some
sense know anything about animals yeah
so you can't ask questions like you know
well which of these animals could could
pick up a suitcase right it's yeah
totally outside the scope of what that's
what that large train circuit is able to
do and at the moment I don't think there
are any any of these machine learning
systems that are capable of answering
those kinds of common-sense questions
you can make it appear as if they do buy
and this is another I would say failing
of the current of the current trends in
AI you can just put in millions and
millions of question-answer pairs like
that and then
you hope that if I give it a new
question that there's there's some
something similar enough in the data set
that it can cobble together some answer
that is right most of the time and
there's a Japanese researcher Noriko RI
who has been able to train a machine
learning system to pass the entrance
exam for the University of Tokyo which
is a very difficult and selective exam
that's pretty good most most students in
Japan obviously failed to do because
University of Tokyo is is the premier
university but she freely admits that
the system has absolutely no idea about
anything it doesn't understand any of
the questions it has no knowledge to
speak of it's just been trained on
enough examples and enough background
text data that it's able to spot in
office distill correlations between what
the words are on the question and
constituents in the question to what the
answer should be but there's no
reasoning process going on at all so my
guess is and I think people like demis
hassabis who's the CEO of deepmind and
one of the authors of the alphago system
so demouth has said that deep deep
learning is going to hit a wall
basically and we're gonna have to go
back and reintegrate all the things that
classical AI worked on the symbolic
techniques the logic reasoning knowledge
representation and so on
and the question is how does that
integration work how does deep learning
get integrated with these kinds of
symbolic techniques and whoever figures
out the answer to that question is gonna
be able to make the next set of
breakthroughs in AI that's the challenge
for our listeners absolutely let me
pause for a second to talk about the
bling kissed app this is a wonderful
little app you can put on your phone
your other mobile device and what it is
is basically a way to figure out what's
going on in some of the best and most
popular books ever written a 15-minute
read will tell you the major points in
what could be a really long and
intimidating read I mean we all love
reading books but there's
major problems number one finding enough
time to do the reading you want and
number two
deciding which books you want to read
let's say all of your friends have been
saying you really should read is n in
the art of motorcycle maintenance but
just from the title it doesn't seem
necessarily up your alley
well you could go to blink Asst you
could get the lowdown on what's going on
in that book and from there you could
decide whether to dig in further with
blinkers to get unlimited access to read
or listen to a massive library of
condensed non-fiction books all the
books you want and all for one low price
and right now for a limited time blink
this has a special offer for mindscape
listeners go to blankest comm slash
mindscape to try it free for seven days
and save 25% off your new subscription
that's blink estelle i NK IST blink is
calm / mind scape start your 7-day free
trial get 25% off
this is great because we have a lot of
the prospects and also worries about
artificial intelligence and how similar
it is to human intelligence on the table
so therefore let's just skip ahead to
the question of should we be worried or
concerned or optimistic about the
prospect of artificial superintelligence
you know given that artificial
intelligence is not very good at
understanding the questions on the Tokyo
entrance exam should we be worried about
AI becoming number one is there a
prospect that will become much smarter
than human beings and number two is that
a prospect we should be worried about so
these are two really important questions
it's really hard to think of more
important questions that we could be
facing so on the first question are we
going to be able to create super
intelligent AI systems I would say that
we will be able to solve these obstacles
I think there are half a dozen major
obstacles major breakthroughs that have
to happen between here and human-level
AI and I already mentioned one of them
which is the ability of systems to form
their decision-making hierarchies which
allow them to cope with complexity and
so if you think of that that's sort of
one breakthrough and as far as we can
tell is about half a dozen of that scale
that that need to happen and it might be
that once we have all those
breakthroughs if the system still don't
work because there's something that we
didn't think of but I think we at that
point would be pretty close and we also
have to remember it doesn't have to be
more capable than humans along every
dimension in order to be something that
we have to worry about so just to give
you an example chimpanzees it turns out
have considerably better short-term
memory than human beings even for
something that's very human like a
string of digits
so chimpanzees I think can remember 20
digit telephone numbers without too much
difficulty and humans can't but I think
chimpanzee still have good reason to
worry about human intellectual
capabilities because we're basically in
the process of destroying them with the
with the capabilities that we have and
in fact for many species on earth the
existential risks that they face is
entirely a consequence of another
species on earth namely us that is more
intelligent than they are so of course
it's reasonable to ask if we create and
entities that are more intelligent than
us is that a good idea right in
particular are we going to be able to
retain control retain power over
entities that are more powerful than we
are it's hard to find good examples in
nature of less powerful species having
power over a more powerful species but
that's what we're being asked to that's
the problem we're being asked to solve
so I think the public discussion of this
topic is confusing a lot of different
things so one is you know is super
intelligent AI imminent in other words
do I need to be worried right now that
something bad is gonna happen right now
and the answer is no AI systems at least
not in the in the existential sense of a
risk to humanity no there is no risk to
humanity but bad things are already
happening with AI systems even ones that
are really really really stupid because
they run on billions of computers
particularly the algorithms that run on
social media that select what you see
what you read what you watch what you
listen to for hours everyday for
billions of people those algorithms I
think are already having a say
negative impact on the world
another question is well should we be
worried right now that something bad is
going to happen in the future and I
think that's the right question to us
because the you know the timelines that
most people think about are on the order
of decades and I'm actually a little
more conservative you know I will
generally say well I expect human level
you know sort of seriously risky AI
capabilities more towards the end of the
century rather than mid century which is
where most a AI researchers think that
will have them so it's entirely
reasonable to be concerned about that
just as if you know if we discovered you
know a previously undetected asteroid
that was quite likely to hit the earth
in 60 or 70 years time it would be quite
reasonable to be worried now about that
future event and actually we are already
worried about that we we already have a
planetary defense agency it's part of
NASA they are busy tracking all these
asteroids they're trying to figure out
what would we do if we detected a
sizable one that really was on a
collision course and so far we haven't
found one that's on a collision course
but so far the statistics show that
we've only detected about 30% of the
objects that are going to come close to
the earth and are large enough to be a
civilization ending event so don't be
too complacent even about that risk now
the risk from AI is a little different
from an asteroid because you know the
impact of an asteroid and why it would
be a bad thing are pretty clear and
straightforward
whereas with AI it's a little harder to
to figure out exactly how things might
go wrong in the same you
same would be true if you asked the
chimpanzees you know a few thousand
years ago okay so so you you've got
these humans they here and they're much
smarter than you how is it all gonna end
the chimpanzees didn't you know would
have a very hard time figuring out how
it was all gonna end for them because it
in some sense it doesn't really matter
you know once you cede control of the
world and your environment and
everything else to another species that
really doesn't care about you then
getting into precise details about how
exactly it all ends seems sort of beside
the point
the point is let's not cede control to
more powerful species if we can help it
so that's the sense in which I think
it's reasonable to be concerned where
we're investing billions of dollars or
hundreds of billions of dollars pushing
forward a technology with no plan for
what to do when we succeed well yeah
okay I mean that was that was great and
there's a lot going on here so I'm just
trying to figure out which direction to
attack and first I mean you mentioned
that we're just overwhelmed with
artificial intelligence programs doing
work for us already
none of them are anything that you would
call super intelligent and so there is
obviously a risk just from not
understanding what they're doing but
that's a different risk than I think
that you're highlighting here at the end
and in a more intelligent species than
us can we be a little bit more definite
about things like species here I mean
how do you imagine this super
intelligent AI existing being embodied
is it you know someone literally writes
a program and C++ or is it sort of
emergently
arising out of the internet is it in a
robot DISA distributed in the cloud what
should we be visualizing so I I
certainly think that the typical
science-fiction depiction for obvious
reasons is that it's in the head of a
single robot yeah and I think that's a
huge mistake for it's extremely unlikely
that that's how thing
would go so it's much more likely that
it would be a you know a composite
system drawing on computational power of
the entire cloud or a good fraction of
it some people would say that it could
the the negative consequences could
emerge from the sort of unanticipated
interaction of many many different
systems and we've already seen this in
the so-called flash crash which was when
a lot of trading algorithms on the stock
market
somehow interacted in a way that we
still don't really understand and then
in the course of about 20 minutes they
wiped a trillion dollars off the value
of the stock market and we had to shut
the stock market down and we had to undo
all those trades and then you know
fortunately the the stock market had
these built-in circuit breakers which
allowed the intervention to take place
but when that kind of thing happens it
has an effect in the real world it
really shook the confidence of investors
in in the operative reasonable operation
of the market and it could have been
much worse so so these unanticipated
interactions are a possibility but I
think the the failure mode that we
anticipate is the consequence of the
standard model of AI whereby we we make
this optimizing machinery and we put in
objectives and then it turns out that
the objective is incomplete or incorrect
in some way and this is not a there's
not a new story right we go back to King
Midas who said I want everything I touch
to turn to gold and that was so that's
the objective that he put into the
machine so to speak and he got exactly
what he asked for and then he realized
that now his food and his drink is
turning to gold and his family is turned
to gold and and then he dies in misery
and starvation so so the standard model
is in fact I think a an engineering
mistake it's a
way of creating systems that relies on
perfection on the part of humans in our
ability to specify objectives and that's
a really it's a really bad idea it's
very light on the part of humans yeah
particularly particularly when the thing
you're putting an objective into is
potentially more powerful and then human
beings are so it could have physical
appendages so it might it might reside
in the cloud but it could still have
physical appendages with which it can
bring about changes in the world but it
doesn't even need to do that you know
when you when you think about Adolf
Hitler and the changes he brought about
it wasn't because of his physical
appendages it was because he basically
did it with words and AI systems can
have impact on the world through words
through communication and the internet
as they already are as social media
algorithms are already impacting the
world even though they have no arms and
legs and they have no laser guns and
nuclear nuclear bombs and all the rest
yeah but I mean I think this is exactly
what I want to sort of maybe it's an
unfair question but I want to really try
to drill in on the physical
manifestation of this I mean there is
the the threat from artificial stupidity
as you said you know algorithms that
don't really do their job well or are
biased or whatever yeah so what I'm
saying is is precisely not that the
algorithm is stupid that it's not doing
its work correctly is that we are
specifying its work incorrectly short
okay but it the algorithm is is
extraordinarily capable at carrying out
the the assigned objective the signed
task in ways that turn out to have
extremely bad side effects so if you
don't believe that's possible then just
think about the fossil fuel industry and
imagine the fossil fuel industry
as an algorithm right no it happens to
have human components that are
replaceable in the are replaced on a
regular basis but as an algorithm it's
trying to optimize the objective of
generating a discounted stream of
quarterly profits or whatever it might
be and is in the process of destroying
the world and we are unable to stop it
so this is a failure mode that we are
already familiar with and it can it can
happen with AI systems just as much as
it can happen with with corporations
that are optimizing an objective and
neglecting the side effects right but
somehow that doesn't I think we all
agree that does not count super
intelligent the fossil fuel industry
it's kind of that's that's the stupidity
that I that I was thinking of not an
ineffectual miss but lack of
self-awareness self reflection it's just
doing its job right I think maybe I'm
misunderstanding but I think when people
use the word super intelligent they
really are imagining something more
human-like right something that knows
what it's doing and wants to do it maybe
it's not wanting to do the right thing
but it has a little bit more
self-control and I'm wondering would
things like that exist where would they
exist how would they manifest their
control in the physical world I think
there's a tendency to anthropomorphize
and we see this in a number of
commentators so Steven Pinker for
example Melanie Mitchell is another one
who who assert that that it's intrinsic
in the nature of intelligence that that
a sufficiently intelligent entity is
going to act in a way that's beneficial
to human beings and I see absolutely no
justification for this a priori for
example right there are millions of
species on earth some of them are much
more numerous
than human beings why wouldn't the AI
system decide to be beneficial to
Antarctic krill you know there's
probably a thousand times more krill
than there are humans so why not be
beneficial to them or why not be
beneficial to bacteria or why be so
parochial right what's wrong with being
beneficial to an alien species on some
star on the other side of the of the
galaxy so you I think the the onus is on
those who believe that somehow this is
magic connection between the capability
for rational decision-making and the
consequence of being beneficial to
humans there is no such magic connection
it has to be designed in and that's
really what human compatibility ninh
that magic connection so that the more
intelligent the AI system the better the
outcome for human beings specifically
not for aliens on the other side of the
galaxy and not for and talked to krill
but for human beings yeah no I'm
completely on your side in thinking
there's no natural tendency toward
having AI be beneficial to humans I'm
just trying to wonder how vivid can we
be about how this AI would hurt us would
it be just massively misdirecting the
food supply would it be a million subtle
interventions on to social media is it
something we can even say anything about
or we should just be worried across a
broad spectrum of bad outcomes so the
difficulty with you know so I can
describe scenarios and of course since I
can describe them you can always say
well okay then we'll just make a rule
against that right and then of course
that scenario won't happen but another
scenario will happen so the kinds of
examples that you see commonly involve
for example side effects that modify our
physical environment and this is sort of
what the fossil fuel companies are doing
in in terms of
adding carbon dioxide to the atmosphere
and so you could imagine that for
example you want to fix that problem you
say okay I would really like carbon
dioxide levels to return to their
pre-industrial concentrations and that
sounds like a great goal honest it's a
perfectly reasonable goal to state to
another human being who already shares
all of the other background preferences
that humans have for the future but if
that's the sole objective then there are
many ways of achieving that objective
for example probably the simplest ways
it will where's all the carbon dioxide
coming from always coming from the
economic activities of humans okay let's
get rid of the humans and so as you say
okay well I didn't mean that what I
meant was you know restore the carbon
dioxide levels and don't kill any people
fine okay then we'll have a decade's
long social media campaign which
convinces people that it's immoral to
have children because those children are
what's responsible for the the gradual
destruction of our planet and so we all
stop having children and the human race
goes extinct and the AI system has
solved its problem without killing any
people and then it you know if there's
anyone left to have a third wish then
they come up with a revised version of
that and then the solution to that
problem kills them off so the the the
issue is that we we haven't noticed this
problem up until recently because our
intelligent systems have been not very
intelligent they're mostly in the lab
they're mostly working on toy problems
and so they don't have consequences on
the world and if they start misbehaving
we have an off switch we switch them off
in fact every robot above a certain size
is legally required to have a big read
off switch usually on the back so that
if it starts misbehaving you can you can
switch it off in an emergency or even a
remote control off switch I did not know
that but
once you get outside the lab you know
the the effects as with social media
algorithms that are directly operating
on the real world can be enormous and
you also have to understand that the off
switch you know is off people often say
oh well if something really bad happens
we can just switch it off but of course
that's like saying you know if I'm
losing to alphago I'll just play a
better move well sorry
whatever better move you might think you
have alphago has already thought of it
and has a way to refute it and whatever
attempt you might make to switch off the
machine the AI system has of course
anticipated that that's a possible
failure mode right the one of the most
obvious ways of not achieving your
objective use that you're dead right you
can't fetch the coffee if you're dead so
the system has already taken pre-emptive
steps to prevent that failure because
it's very good at achieving the
objectives that we give it not because
it really wants to be alive there's
nothing to do with self-preservation
there's no instinct it's a logical
consequence of having an objective
that's fixed that a system wants to
remain alive in order to achieve the
objective so I guess there's no reason
to keep the audience's in suspense
anymore I mean the real purpose of your
book is to actually propose a new
strategy for dealing with exactly this
problem you think that we should be
giving our AI systems a different kind
of goal than we usually do yes in fact
you could argue we should not be giving
the AI system a goal at least not one
that is precisely defined and known to
the AI system because it's exactly when
that AI system believes that it knows
the objective correctly that whatever
action it comes up with in furtherance
of that objective it then sort of
believes that this is the correct action
to do and doesn't tolerate necessarily
interference from people who are jumping
up and down
you know to stop doing that you're
destroying the world from the AI systems
point of view that's just noise right
it's just it's me you know my mouth
flapping open and closed so what it's
pursuing the optimal solution to the
objective that we gave it so the the
solution that's proposed in the book has
so two two main parts right the the
first part is that we design systems in
such a way that they're their only
objective is whatever it is that humans
want the future to be like so we use the
word preferences which is the term that
economists use but it doesn't just mean
like preferences between different kinds
of pizza it really means you know out of
the possible futures that the way the
way the the world could unfold in future
how would you like it to unfold and so
this is what the AI system is supposed
to be helping us with but the second
part of the solution is that it knows
that it doesn't know what those
preferences are and this avoids the
problem of a machine that is given a
fixed objective and and believes that
that is the only objective and therefore
has to be pursued at all costs so if we
if we say to the AI system that we don't
like what it's doing we are conveying
additional preference information to the
Machine and it then is rational for the
machine to revise its plan because now
it's learned a bit more about what we
want and don't want and if it comes up
with a plan that says okay I can fix
carbon dioxide by getting rid of all the
people so it knows that we want to fix
the carbon dioxide let's say it doesn't
know where the the people want to be
alive or dead well what's the rational
thing for it to do if it just wants to
optimize the carbon dioxide then it just
kills all the people hmm if it knows
that it doesn't know whether the people
want to be alive or dead then it's
reasonable in fact it's rational for
to ask permission it says okay I've got
this plan here's how we solve it we kill
all the people and then carbon dioxide
goes back to normal and then you say no
that's not quite what I meant
right so these solutions like asking
permission deferring to human
instruction and also allowing oneself to
be switched off these behaviors don't
have to be programmed in we don't have
to sort of put special rules and
regulations into the AI system to make
it do that those behaviors are just a
logical consequence of the way we frame
the problem their rationale for the AI
system to to do its rationale for it to
ask permission its rationale for it to
allow itself to be switched off because
it doesn't want to do whatever it is
that would cause us to switch it off and
it doesn't know what that might be but
if there's a danger that it might do
something we really don't like then it
would prefer to be switched off in order
to avoid that from happening yeah I
certainly like the idea this initial
uncertainty in what it thinks the humans
would prefer is this something that just
by the way have you written AI
algorithms that have this feature and
and turn them loose and watch them
behave yes in in tiny little worlds and
the the mathematical description of this
we call it an assistance game so so the
word game is a general term actually
that economists used I mean any
situation where there are multiple
entities that are making decisions and
here we could imagine just two entities
a human being and a machine and the
machines objective is whatever it is the
human wants that's what I want right but
the machine doesn't know what that is
and so you can set up that game and for
example you can make a little grid world
and you can put a human in there and
simulated human and a simulated robot
and you can solve the game you can
calculate what is the solution to this
game for both the human and the
robo and when you look at the solutions
you see what you hope you see that in
fact the human tries to teach the robot
sometimes the human shows the robot what
not to do right taketake basically kind
of takes the robot by the hand and says
look you could go over here but that's a
big pit don't go in there right and then
you should go over here and this is
where you should sit because this is a
nice place to be and the robot you know
other versions of the game the robot
asked permission in some versions of
this game the robot and the human
actually devised a little protocol where
the robot kind of comes and asks a
question and the human gives them a
yes/no and then the robot goes away and
does does the right thing so we're just
a beginning of this process of exploring
the nature of solutions to these kinds
of formal mathematical problems but what
what we've seen so far is that first of
all the kinds of behaviors that the
robot exhibits are exactly what we hope
they're they defer they ask permission
they learn from the human about what the
human wants and they help the human
achieve whatever it is the human wants
to achieve and interestingly read the
one way of thinking about it is that
this game is a strict generalization of
the classical notion of a machine
pursuing a fixed objective because now
it's not a fixed objective it's a it's a
uncertain objective rather than a
certain objective so it's strictly a
more general problem-solving situation
and the kinds of behaviors that are
exhibited are much richer and more
interesting as a result it certainly
bears a family resemblance to Bayesian
inference right where we have some set
of priors with the probability of all
them and then we update on the basis of
more information so I'm wondering would
we expect that such a system would
become less and less uncertain over time
about what it thinks the motivations are
I mean do these systems grow old and
crotchety and harder to change their
minds
in a sense yes I think in a practical
you know in a practical sense it's it's
pretty unlikely that machines would ever
acquire enough information to be able to
predict our preferences particularly
about things that have never been
experienced in the real world so for
example you you can look through there
are whole books written about what
people want you know in the development
economists write these books and moral
philosophers write these books people
come up with long lists of you know what
what are the needs of human beings what
you know what but none of those books
will you find what color do people
prefer the sky to be hmm and that's
because up to now no one's bothered to
change the color of the sky to find to
find out how upset people are as a
result so it's unlikely that an AI
system is going to be able to predict
our responses to changes in the color of
the sky other than just sort of being
generally upset that it's not what it
used to be but maybe we'd like the new
one better actually I don't know so but
there's also this sort of fundamental
fact that there's a lot we don't know
about our own preferences so there's
genuine what we call epistemic
uncertainty in meaning that it doesn't
matter how much I think about it I
actually have to go out and experience
something I have to get real actual
empirical experience in the world in
order to learn more about my preferences
and there's a there's a recent book by
la Paul who's the philosopher called
transformative experience and she uses
the example of the durian fruit we just
had Laurie as a guest on the podcast and
we talked all about transformative
experiences here right and the yeah so
so independently I came up with the
durian fruit as an example of this so
it's a fruit that's extremely smelly and
some people absolutely
we love it and they think it's the most
marvelous food on the surface of the
earth and there are other people who
utterly despise it and there have been
cases of where there was a cargo of
durian on an aeroplane and some of the
passengers could not stand it so they
actually mutiny on the airplane and
forced the captain to to go back and
land at the airport and unload the cargo
of durians because it was so unbearable
so it's clearly something that elicits
either extremely positive or extremely
negative preferences but I have no idea
which one I am because I've never tried
it I've never smelt it so I have real
epistemic uncertainty about how I would
enjoy a future where I'm eating lots of
jury so in that you know and very
similar kinds of arguments apply to much
more practical kinds of things like well
you know would you imagine a school
leaver you know would you like to be a
coal miner or a librarian right those
are only two jobs we have right now lad
coal miner librarian which is it going
to be
of course that's 16 years old you have
no idea how much you're going to enjoy
being a coal miner how much you're going
to enjoy being a librarian so you have a
you have some vague feelings about it
you might have seen references to these
professions and you've got some images
in your mind and little bits of evidence
here and there but of course you could
certainly be wrong if you made one
prediction or another so this real
uncertainty about human preferences
within humans means that there is no
practical way that the AI system is
going to reach a situation of perfect
knowledge but the way Bayesian inference
works actually is that unless you unless
you make certain kinds of mistakes in
the way you set up the problem at the
beginning the Bayesian process only
reaches certainty when it's correct yeah
so as so as long as you make sure that
your prior beliefs are sufficiently
broad as to encompass every possible
human preference structure which is a
tall order I agree but let's say
if you can do that then you only
approach certainty as you approach
having correct beliefs about human
preference structure so in that
situation you might not mind too much
you know the the AI system stops asking
permission because it all it knows what
you're going to say so it doesn't need
to ask permission so it becomes sort of
like the perfect Butler and if you've
read peih-gee Woodhouse and his books
where Jeeves is the butler and Bertie
Wooster's the aristocrat Jeeves actually
in some ways knows Bertie Wooster better
than Bertie knows himself and always
anticipate what his master needs and
wants and manages to do it in advance so
it would be a little bit like that but I
think as I say it would be very unlikely
that we would approach any degree of
certainty in any in any finite amount of
time how how much do we have to deeply
think about the idea of a preference I
mean in the usual and the standard model
I guess of AI where you just program in
a utility function that is operationally
what you mean but here you're using the
word preference to mean something about
human beings right it's the human
preferences that are supposed to be
learned by the AI if we push it hard
enough to implement in software is it
even clear what human preference is I
mean not only do humans not know what
their preferences are they might change
they might be inconsistent right
internally incoherent are there ways to
deal with this yes so these are great
questions it's it's certainly the case
that when economists or behavioral
economists do a lot of experiments to
try to figure out the the actual
preferences of humans even for something
as simple as money so let alone the
color of the sky or what kind of piece
do you want but just money you know how
much do you like money and risks
involving money money today versus money
tomorrow and I would say that the the
consensus is these experiment
is that consistency of preferences seems
to be fairly well supported and so
consistency meaning that you do you do
appear to be able to to rank different
outcomes in a consistent way but we
don't exactly seem to follow some of the
at least straightforwardly if you
interpret the other axioms of
rationality we don't quite seem to
follow those and we seem to have our own
peculiar ways of making decisions and
Daniel Kahneman who's a leading
psychologists and another Nobel Prize
winner in economics has studied actual
human preferences and we seem to have
actually sort of two minds so his
explanation is that there's an
experiencing self which is sort of the
moment-to-moment amount of enjoyment or
pain that you're experiencing and then
there's a remembering self and in
standard economic theory there
remembering self is sort of supposed to
add up the experiencing self experiences
and and say okay well that's how good
this was it's the sort of the sum of all
the pleasures and pains that I
experienced but it turns out empirically
that the remembering self does something
quite a bit different so in particular
the remembering self really remembers
the the most pleasurable most painful
part of the experience and also the part
that was most recent so they call this
the peak end theory so the peak and the
end of the experience seem to be very
salient in how you remember the
desirability or undesirability of
something and that's pretty hard to
reconcile with standard economic models
but actually when you think about it
it's clear that memory and expectations
are quite reasonably folded in to human
decision-making because if I have a bad
experience I might remember that
for my whole life and so it isn't just
the experience itself that was bad it's
the recurring memory of it that's gonna
be bad and and that recurring memory is
going to remember the worst thing right
so some is if I ask you what was the
worst thing that ever happened in your
life and probably maybe three or four
things pop into your head and there's
things you think about every so often
and some people even have to have to go
through psychiatric treatment to try to
extinguish some of these memories that
are ruining the rest of their lives so
so it might be that in fact what the
remembering self is doing is perfectly
rational if you incorporate memory and
expectation into how you evaluate the
costs or the the benefits of some
experience so I would say that at the
moment we're a long way from
understanding the many layered nature of
human preferences and so on but you know
if we really are inconsistent so for
example if our transit is our if our
preferences are intransitive
in other words they kind of go around in
circles then there's nothing that a eye
system can do because you know any pizza
the AI system gives you you say well
actually I prefer this other one and you
gives you like when it's not sure I
prefer the first one and of course
you'll never be satisfied and there's
there's really nothing that any any
discipline of building artificial
systems could possibly do to satisfy
inconsistent preferences so but we you
know we can give you a pizza as you know
as opposed to no pizza at all right and
probably prefer some kind of pizza to
starving to death that will make sure
you get some kind of pizza we might end
up learning a lot about psychology from
the way that the AI determines what our
preferences are in practice like which
might be different than what we say they
are when we try to state them yeah I see
I think that this is probably the
conceptually the most difficult part of
the research agenda that I'm proposing
is the gap between the idealized model
of a human that has stable preferences
consistent preferences about the future
and the reality of actual humans and I
think particularly stability is
conceptually very difficult to deal with
if uh if a human beings preferences can
change in other words what I want
tomorrow to be like today is different
from what I want tomorrow to be like
when I get to tomorrow then which of my
two solves is the AI system supposed to
satisfy myself today or myself tomorrow
it's hard to pick apart that problem
philosophically and then practically if
human beings preferences can change
which clearly they do we're not born
with a whole complex set of preferences
then how do you make sure that the AI
system doesn't satisfy preferences by
changing those preferences yeah make
them easier to satisfy well what I was
gonna say was how can we be sure that
the AI won't just change its mind about
what its preferences are hard to satisfy
the human preferences like if we really
are imagining a eyes that are super
intelligent must less much less just
intelligent can we really also assume
that we're baking in their fundamental
motivational structure or is that
something subject to editing on their
own part so this is an interesting set
of questions having to do with our
ability to prove mathematical theorems
about the software that we build so we
already have the capability to prove
that algorithms are correct that they
behave according to some specification
and this capability is getting more and
more sophisticated and we use it even in
areas like machine learning which you
might think well how do you know how
could you possibly prove anything about
an algorithm that learns but it turns
out that you can and you can typically
we're able to show that we expect to get
you know performance within
small epsilon of the desired performance
and and that will happen with very high
probability so that's the kind of
theorem that that we prove all the time
so the the idea here would be we would
set up the general framework for how for
how the system operates and it would
have learning components strung together
in the right way and then what you prove
is that no matter how good each of those
components becomes the system as a whole
still conforms to the this required
design where it satisfies these
principles there are some tricky parts
to this so traditionally when we when we
prove theorems about software we're kind
of assuming that the parts of the
program that we want to remain fixed
remain fixed and you can prove that this
piece of software can never overwrite
itself and and change it's sort of
Constitution so to speak but there's
another set of theorems you'd have to
prove which is that there's no
circumstance under which the software
would convince a human being to go in
and overwrite the Constitution and
that's a much more difficult kind of
guarantee to provide and this comes
about you know we've noticed this in in
computer security where we we prove that
security protocols are correct but then
we find out that there's what we call a
side channel and side channels include
things like you know listening to the
sound of the keyboard by bouncing a
laser beam off the window of your office
building or measuring the electrical
current in the main supply that's going
into the computer and then being able to
extract information from these from
these channels and when you put an AI
system into the real world you
automatically create this side channel
which is that the AI system can convince
the human being to make physical changes
to the memory of the machine and its
software and we have to make sure that
that side channel is somehow cut off
this all right this is a lot to think
about I gotta say this is a very good
episode for food-for-thought purposes
I'll just close with just giving you a
chance to sort of speculate about the
future I mean what what do you think is
going to be the vision of AI that comes
true 50 years from now I mean what
should we be looking for overall given
all that we've talked about over the
last hour
so assuming things go well so assuming
we've we figure out how the design AI
systems in such a way that we retain
control over them and I think this is
actually feasible there's a lot of very
hard algorithm design and engineering
work to be done to take the basic
framework that I've described and turn
it into technology that will replace and
supersede all of the AI technology
that's already out there but assuming
that works and assuming that we overcome
these conceptual obstacles and achieve
human-level or sometimes called
general-purpose or super intelligent AI
that becomes a tool that enables us to
have a much better civilization than the
one we currently have and is you know
our civilization is the best we can do
with the brains that we have but if we
had access to much better brains even if
they don't belong to us we get to use
them and we can have a better world than
the one we have right now we could I
think quite easily without imagining the
sort of sci-fi advances of you know
eternal life or fast and light travel
you know curing all disease but just
using AI and robotics technology to
deliver the goods and services that you
know well-off people in the West take
the granted so giving that sort of
standard of life to everyone on earth
would be it's about a tenfold increase
in the GDP of the world which when you
calculate the sort of cash equivalent
value what the economists call net
present value is thirteen and a half
trillion sorry thirteen and a half
thousand trillion dollars so just for
comparison you know the GDP of the u.s.
is on the order of twenty trillion
dollars a year so we're talking about
hundreds of times larger than the GDP of
the US or in fact the GDP of the world
so that's the cash value and and when
you look at the investments the tens or
hundreds of billions of dollars that
people are talking about
it's absolutely miniscule in comparison
to the potential benefits so we could
enter a golden era in a way where we no
longer have to fight about access to the
wherewithal of life which is one of the
main reasons we've been killing each
other since the beginning of time I mean
there are other reasons like religion
that we kill each other but at least we
would get rid of this this reason so
some people have said look if we have
this AI that can do everything that
human beings can do and sort of can do
it for us essentially for free then
what's left for human beings what role
do we have where do we find a useful
purpose in life if there's nothing that
we can do that's better than what the
Machine can do and I think this is a
really important question for us and
presumably if the machines understand
our preferences they know that we don't
want a future of idle enfeeble meant
right where we essentially become couch
potatoes for the rest of time where we
don't learn we don't try we don't do
anything of any value with our lives
because that's sort of not what we want
the future to be like
so the AI systems will have to say at
some point you know no we're not gonna
keep tying your shoelaces for you you
humans have have got to learn and keep
learning to do stuff for yourself so
that's going to be an interesting
discussion to have in a few decades time
well you've certainly given us a very
good set of reasons to believe that we
should all be thinking hard about this
and trying to figure out what's going to
happen next do it Russell thanks so much
for being on the mindscape podcast
pleasure show very nice talking to you
[Music]
you
[Music]